currently yes
they can however
I think the debate that we're having is about the um
ethics of being able to share all of your views online
and the possible consequences of that
now I'm going to agree wholeheartedly with people defending this creator
saying that she is self aware and she wants to do the work to change
and she acknowledges that hating children is not acceptable
and she should fix that
my issue and my opinion again
it's just an opinion and especially coming as somebody who is a parent
my opinion is that there are a lot of people who are going to benefit
from following her healing journey
and doing likewise amounts of self reflection and therapy
however the internet is a large
anonymous and uncontrollable space
so when you say things like I hate kids
it's from trauma and I'm working through it
there is going to be a percentage of people who that content reaches
who stops at the I hate kids
and this is why
portion of her message
and will never go through the required self reflection and therapy
to fix that problem
they will simply feel validated and vindicated
and justified in knowing that there is a reason why they feel this way
and of course there's a reason why they feel this way
and of course it is linked to trauma
and I do think that there is a potential for this type of content
or this type of messaging
to help those people
my issue um
is that the potential harm that it could also cause
two children as a protected and vulnerable class of people
there is no other group of people
that someone would come on the internet and say
I hate these people
but it's because of my own personal traumas and experiences
and have that be a well received message
accept if it's children
that's what I'm trying to discuss
I think as a society
there is a sphere of acceptability of things for reason
in order to protect the collective community
and my priority
as a member of a community
is to protect the most vulnerable person in a situation
and in this case it is children
I think talking through your hate
I think deconstructing it is um
valuable and I think it is absolutely something people should do
when they recognize those feelings within themselves
however because of the anonymity and vast open space and unchecked
you don't get to choose who sees your message and how they take it
I think that there is a debate to be had
about the potential harm that it could also cause
not instead of
but also
and because that harm affects people that I deeply feel protective about
I'm going to draw attention to that